I know one thing wherever we go
this family
is our fortress
Welcome back everyone this will be my brand new
avatar 2 trailer video the way of water they
finally released a trailer for the movie that
it took 14 years for them to get out almost
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos obviously i'll
do videos for the movie when we get a little bit
closer to it coming out they release some more
trailers it's gonna be their big christmas movie
this year because it's a fox movie technically but
fox was bought by disney so technically it's
a disney movie now but now everybody's kind
of racking their brains trying to remember what
happened during the first movie because it's been
so long and they haven't been doing a ton behind
the scenes like they've been showing off a little
here and there over the last couple of
years but not really if you guys didn't
realize james cameron has actually been
working on four different sequels there'll
be five avatar movies total and they're kind
of doing a star wars type of thing like with
the original movies the original six movies
where you do the saga of anakin skywalker
where like these sequels all the movies follow
jake sully's family across the different films
this first film avatar two the way of water
is obviously all based on this water-based
culture that they travel to but obviously this
trailer teases there's been a lot of changes in
the pandora planet itself and the culture between
their different peoples the humans in the knobby
over this 14 years that have gone by one of
the biggest changes is that now they have three
children one of them is an adopted human child and
two of them are naturally born na'vi children so
jake sully and neytiri are both just a little bit
older even though they both look like they looked
in the first movie they don't look that much
older because they're basically giant blue aliens
the human child that they've adopted is netayam
this is what he looks like obviously they follow
the na'vi culture so even though he is human he
is adopted their ways as he's gotten older the way
they explain his character is that he was the son
of some of the human colonists who came to mind
the unobtainium because remember unobtainium
is like the big ore that they're trying to
mine there is a source of the entire conflict
during the first movie he's the son of some of
those humans who wound up dying during one of the
conflicts so he was orphaned they just adopted him
after some tragedy relating to that their younger
na'vi son they've had is named lo'ak this is what
he looks like and then their youngest natural-born
na'vi daughter is named tuk this is what she looks
like she's about eight years old early in the
trailer you see their family flying and running
across the different landscapes of pandora
as they head to this water try this new place
all these shots are basically their family just
changing their location on pandora the official
synopsis of the plot says set more than a decade
after the events of the first film it said about
14 years after the first film avatar the way of
water begins to tell the story of the sully family
jake sully's family the trouble that follows them
in the links they go to keep each other safe the
battles they fight to stay alive and the tragedies
they endure across the years across these four
sequels james cameron said that so much is going
on on pandora it's such a big planet with so many
different cultures that each of the different
sequels is meant to feel like a completely
different movie even though they are all sequels
they're all interconnected in loose ways but like
each sequel isn't gonna have 14 years in between
them i think the idea they're hyping up here in
the trailer and what's going on in the synopsis is
that the sequels will just follow their family as
their children get older eventually by the time
you get to the last movie avatar 5 whatever the
title of that winds up being their children will
be the main characters and i believe they actually
did film a lot of the footage for the sequels
while they were filming the footage for the second
movie like they didn't just work on the second
movie that's one of the reasons why it's taken
14 years to finish all these movies they weren't
just working on that one movie if you follow
what a lot of the actors said after the first
film because james cameron had been hyping up
the sequels when he was releasing that first film
way back in 2009 stephen lang was saying that he
would be back somehow but he didn't know exactly
how that was going to work because it's a sci-fi
film obviously james cameron did confirm that
stephen lang's character colonel miles quaritch
would be the main antagonist of all the movies
all the sequels but the form that his villain
character would take would change between all the
sequels there'd be like this evolution of his evil
character over all these sequels i think a lot of
this has to do with the more mystical nature the
energy transference the way he transfers his mind
his soul to his avatar na'vi body at the end of
the film like his consciousness is able to survive
his physical body's death so i think it's going to
be a similar situation for steven lang's character
but like for instance he said that sigourney
weaver is coming back to the movie but she'll
be a completely different character so it is
possible that stephen lang just plays a completely
different character and it's just as his voice
sounds very similar to miles korch's voice even
though his villain character in the sequels has no
relation to the miles korich kernel character but
i wouldn't completely bet out that there's going
to be some connection between his original colonel
character and what's going on with his new villain
character it just feels weird for james cameron
to bring back all these same actors and say no
no they're completely different even though they
sound exactly the same some of the shots they show
you during the trailer are meant to mirror shots
from that first avatar trailer back in 2009 like
this is a shot of netery's eyes just like you saw
during the first avatar trailer so many years ago
a lot of the music from the trailer is meant
to feel very similar to the music from that
first original trailer way back in the day even
though there's no dialogue during the trailer it's
actually pretty decent trailer even though people
say you know will this be just as big a hit as the
original one it probably won't make quite as much
money as the original one but one of the important
things that you have to remember is that you
never bet against james cameron i know one thing
wherever we go he didn't direct that last
terminator movie like he was very loosely
involved with that last terminator movie this
time this movie is completely his from the ground
up from start to finish which is why i think that
he'll surprise people with how successful it winds
up being as they fly their family to this new
water-based culture in a different part of pandora
two of the other really big characters that he's
introducing are both kate winslet and vin diesel's
character now he didn't say who vin diesel was
playing but he did say that kate winslet is a
big part of this water-based tribe i think that
this character here is meant to be kate winslet's
character so i'm assuming that he would let vin
diesel play like some small funny groot-like
character like he's playing some big badass
this character is probably the leader of this
water-based tribe or just someone really important
inside the tribe that's probably going to be vin
diesel's character one of the other major changes
in the culture of pandora the face of the planet
itself seems like the na'vi have started working
with humans even though at the end of the last
movie they expelled all them off the planet the
way they teased stephen lang's villain this movie
they say an ancient threat resurfaces jake must
fight a difficult war against the humans it does
sound like steven lang's character is connected to
his original character like it's his consciousness
who has survived or is his body who somehow
survived the accident at the end of the film
and somehow that gets twisted with the more
mystical nature of what's going on on pandora
and that's how he goes from being a more
contemporary type of traditional threat to a more
ancient type of threat like it's a darth vader
emperor situation you meet the emperor that
somehow has something to do with what's going
on with stephen lang's character and his villain
character slowly evolves into an emperor-like
character towards the end of the last film
you have to imagine jake sully's character meeting
the stephen lang villain character again after 14
years it's just like darth vader meeting obi-wan
kenobi inside the death star at last we meet again
the circle is now complete when i left you i
was but the learner now i am the master which
because this is all part of the disney umbrella
you're thinking about the obi-wan kenobi episodes
with darth vader and obi-wan kenobi's rematch
set 10 years after revenge of this said don't
worry i will be doing videos for the obi-wan
kenobi episodes starting in a couple weeks
those are going to be crazy in a really really
cool way i think what they're slowly hyping up
is that eventually the humans who are good will
start working with the navi and it'll be like navi
plus good humans against whatever major
threat winds up rising up through the rest
of the sequels like obviously the threat
is very localized to pandora right now
but i think eventually the stephen lang villain
character whatever this ancient threat is will
evolve to become a much much bigger galactic
level problem towards the end of the sequels
the other real big thing they just do in this
trailer is show you many of the other locations
of pandora even though most the movie is localized
around this one particular water tribe i think the
idea through the sequels though is that they will
travel to different major locations in pandora so
that they all look very different even though
it's the same planet for the most part though
all the major characters who were still alive at
the end of the last film are coming back for this
film as well so in the way that star wars sequels
had this big time jump between episode 1 phantom
menace and episode 2 attack of the clones this is
kind of the same situation it'd be like if they
had waited 10 years in real life after phantom
menace to actually release attack of the clones
and even though i'm using the prequels example
this movie is not a prequel it's obviously a
sequel to the original avatar movie but if you
have any big questions about what's going on in
the movie just leave them in the comments below
like i said my obi-wan kenobi episodes will start
in a couple weeks so i'll be doing bonus videos
for that really soon too we'll get more footage
for obi-wan kenobi versus darth vader really
soon i've got a whole bunch of doctor strange two
multiverse of madness videos planned for specific
things in the movies if you have any requests for
that too post them in the comments below everyone
click here for my full breakdown easter eggs for
the entire movie right here and click here for
my full doctor strange 2 post credit scene video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!